Good morning. Hank
It's Tuesday aggressively unscripted video incoming big day around here first off my new book Turtles All the Way Down has a cover! Look!
It's right there. It was designed by Rodrigo Corral
Who did the cover for The Fault in Our Stars, and it's beautiful
And I think it really captures the feeling of the thought spirals that are at the center of the book, and I hope that you
like it. By the way, this is the actual cover, but it is not the actual book it is wrapped around Paper Towns.
I know some people are disappointed by the lack of actual turtles,
but they'll also probably be
disappointed by the lack of actual turtles in the book. There is however this amazing gif (pronounced "jif") or possibly gif (pronounced "gif") if you want to enjoy
actual turtles all the way down. Okay also today
I am reading the final final final manuscript for Turtles All the Way Down because it is going to the printer tomorrow.
This probably also means that I'm reading the book in its entirety for the last time ever because once something is published and I can't
change anything I find it
unbearable to read it. So it's kind of an emotional day because you know for the last 6 years this book has been
mostly mine and after today, it won't be mine anymore. It'll belong to the people who read it and that's exciting, but it's also
ha- I- Umm (Other mouth sounds)
It's hard to desclibe the feeling. Desclibe? It's very hard to desclibe the feeling I just really hope people like the book
but you know starting tomorrow, there's nothing I can do. Let's talk about signing. Here's the situation I've signed
184,000 sheets of paper I am on the first of the two turtles
I've got eight boxes left at 16,000 sheets which will take about thirty two hours and I've got to be done by Monday.
Now I know I would already be done
If I had just not gone to Venice, but I liked going to Venice
so I've got to finish signing and then there is the small matter of
reconnecting the sheets with their boxes. There are a LOT of
Boxes in my basement right now and also a lot of signed sheets. How do I get the sheets neatly inside the boxes? Well,
I'm glad you asked I get to use my Electro Jogger! The Electro Jogger is this amazing piece of 20th Century technology
That exists only to line up sheets of paper, and it is truly magical.
Oh, on the subject of signed books Amazon has sold out of their allotment of probably signed copies of Turtles All the Way Down
But there are still lots of copies available
Books-A-Million has a lot for instance you can always find out more at probablysignedturtles.com, but yes
They are still available. While we're talking about books, and I realized that this video is a little bit scattered
I've been reading a lot of poetry lately
I don't know why I guess that's just the way that my brain wants to process text at the moment and there are two books
that I would really like to recommend is Counting Dissent by Clint Smith
This is a very small book, but it packs a punch.
It's got funny moments like there's a poem called when they tell you the
Brontosaurus never existed the first line of which is "you will wonder what kind of precedent we are setting here," but at other times
It's gut wrenching, it's sad
It's just brilliant also Solo by Kwame Alexander, and Mary Rand has I've been a fan of Kwame Alexander's for a long time
But this book is really special ok so book recommendation signing cover literally mispronouncing the word describe
Absolutely no transitions of any kind right there is one more thing. Which is that Hank
and I are going on tour when Turtles All the Way Down comes out in October
I'm so excited this will be our first tour together since 2012.
I don't yet know exactly where we'll be going so that information will be forthcoming
But it will probably be only in the United States
I know, I'm sorry, but yes there will be tour details in the coming weeks
And I hope to see a lot of you as we traverse the country. Alright Hank
I have to get back to reading my book for the last time before it can never ever be changed again
I will see you on Friday